die iss die internationale raumstation
wurde evakuiert spacex crashte rakete in
eine landeplattform und wir befinden uns
in einem neuen er zeitalter diese und
weitere spannende themen gibt es jetzt
bei den kriegs und pop life news
evakuierung auf der iss am vergangenen
montag wurde auf der internationalen
raumstation iss alarm ausgelöst grund
dafür war dass einige instrumente einen
erhöhten druck im kühlsystem
festgestellt haben kurz darauf wurde
zusätzlich ein erhöhter kabinendruck
festgestellt dieses kann im schlimmsten
fall ein ammoniak leck bedeuten
daraufhin wurde die gesamte crew in den
russischen teil der iss evakuiert dieser
ist wie alle anderen teile luftdicht
isolier bar
alle sechs crewmitglieder verraten
einige stunden im russischen teil bis
die nasa die daten analysiert hatte
alles deutete auf einen fehler der
instrumente in zwei astronauten
untersuchten kurz darauf den betroffenen
teil der raumstation mit atemmasken
fanden allerdings kein leck seit
donnerstag arbeiten wieder alle ss
mitglieder wie gewohnt an ihren
projekten die nasa sucht unterdessen
nach dem auslöser für den fehlalarm ein
computer back oder fehlerhafte sensoren
sind wahrscheinlich der grund das hoch
giftige ammoniak wird im us modul unter
anderem zur kühlung des strom
kreislaufes eingesetzt dazu strömt es in
flüssiger form durch einen geschlossenen
leitungskreis lauf im russischen bereich
auf der ice es wird ein anderes
kühlmittel verwendet zum denken brauchen
wir ein smartphone viele von euch kennen
die aussage bestimmt beim lernen handy
und computer aus das lenkt alles nur ab
der forscher aus missouri haben nun eine
interessante studie zu diesem thema
durchgeführt wird sich iphone-benutzer
mussten in einem großen textblock
einzelne wörter finden
beim ersten test lag es smartphone neben
ihnen auf dem schreibtisch beim zweiten
durchgang wurde ihm das handy unter
einem vorwand entfernt und gemeinerweise
während des tests angerufen bei jedem
durchgang wurden blutdruck und
herzfrequenz gemessen
das ergebnis ist eindeutig die probanden
konnten sich viel schlechter
konzentrieren als ihnen das smartphone
weggenommen wurde
zudem hatten die probanden mehr angst
und fühlten sich unwohl und ihre
ergebnisse in den wörther rätseln fielen
ebenfalls schlechter aus all das ließe
darauf schließen dass das smartphone für
viele menschen eine erweiterung ihrer
selbst zeit wenn dieser teil von uns
fehlt und wir nicht mehr erreichbar sind
dann sinkt unsere
konzentrationsfähigkeit
dramatisch die wissenschaftler empfehlen
deshalb sogar das iphone oder jedes
andere smartphone dass man hat immer
dabei zu haben wenn es darum geht
aufgaben zu lösen die viel
aufmerksamkeit erfordern
hallo mein name ist patrick und ich bin
aktuell der praktikant bei clixoom der
christoph hat bei diesen partnern ein
kleines problem mit seinem mikrofon
bekommen aber genau deshalb bin ich ja
da ich nehme jetzt hier den kleinen part
auf deshalb wünsche ich euch viel spaß
asteroid an der erde vorbei ende januar
wird ein asteroid an der erde
vorbeifliegen
der asteroid hat einen durchmesser von
über 500 metern und verfehlt die erde
voraussichtlich am 26 januar um etwa 12
millionen kilometer mit einem teleskop
oder vielleicht sogar im starken
fernglas könnt ihr den asteoriden sogar
beobachten die entfernung in der der
asturier an uns vorbei rauscht
entspricht ungefähr der dreifachen
distanz zwischen erde und mond
bisher wurde noch nie ein asteroid in
ähnlicher größe registriert der so nah
an der erde vorbeigeflogen ist
der gesteinsbrocken mit dem kryptischen
namen 2004 bl 86 wurde erstmals 2004
entdeckt er kreist um die sonne und wird
das nächste mal in circa 200 jahren bei
uns vorbeikommen
vorher kommt allerdings noch der
asteroid 1999 anc vorbei im jahre 2027
würde er an uns vorbeifliegen und dabei
nur die entfernung zwischen erde und
mond haben asteoriden sind
gesteinsbrocken die um die sonne kreisen
ähnlich wie kometen gelten sie als
überreste aus der entstehungszeit
unseres sonnensystems space extrakte
crasht in landeplattform das private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex unternahmen
am vergangenen samstag in spektakulären
versuch wir haben im vorfeld hier in den
news darüber berichtet und nachdem die
felgen neuen rakete das dragon modul zur
iss der internationalen raumstation
geschossen hatte sollte sie auf einer
plattform im meer landen
wie in diesem video zu sehen ist
erreichte rakete die plattform viel zu
schnell und vor allem mit einem
abgesteckten winkel die rakete
explodiert grund für die explosive
landung des space ex das dem lande
system da geht kurz vor der landung die
hydraulische flüssigkeit ausgehen
daraufhin verlor die rakete die balance
trotzdem wurde der versuch als großer
erfolg gewertet im voraus rechnete das
unternehmen mit gerade einmal 50 prozent
erfolgschance bei optimalen bedingungen
allein dass die rakete die plattform
berührte ist schon ein großer
fortschritt in zwei bis drei wochen will
das unternehmen die direkt den nächsten
versuch starten dann mit wesentlich mehr
hydraulische flüssigkeit die plattform
diese großes während fußballfeld wurde
bei dem unfall übrigens nur leicht
beschädigt und kann wieder verwendet
werden
spex arbeitet seit jahren daran ihre
raketen wieder verwendbar zu machen die
herstellungskosten für eine falcon 9
rakete belaufen sich auf knapp 47
millionen euro
während der treibstoff gerade mal 175
1000 euro kostet allen masc gründer von
spacex vergleicht einen raketenstart mit
einer brandneuen boeing 747 die man nach
einem einzigen flug wieder verschrottet
die wiederverwendung von akten könnte
eine neue ära der raumfahrt an leuten in
der flüge ins all um vieles vieles
billiger werden
neues erdzeitalter die menschheit bringt
unseren planeten an seine grenzen vier
der neuen natürlichen belastungsgrenzen
der erde haben wir bereits überschritten
das berichten internationale experten in
der fachzeitschrift science klimawandel
biodiversität landnutzung und
biochemische kreislauf in allen diesen
bereichen hat der mensch das natürliche
system aus dem gleichgewicht gebracht
und das quasi von jetzt auf gleich wenn
man den zeitraum mit den geologisch
üblichen phasen vergleicht 11.700 jahre
dauerte das holozän die wissenschaftler
der schule verkünden nun ein neues
geologisches zeitalter das anthropozän
auf den tag genau am 14 juli 1945 als
die erste atombombe explodierte begann
das neue zeit
seit diesem tag ist bis 1988
durchschnittlich alle zehn tage eine
atombombe explodiert die erdschichten
die seit dem entstehen sind radioaktiv
seit 1950 haben außerdem die anzahl der
menschen in den städten die weltweit
energie und wasserverbrauch und die
verschmutzung der atmosphäre extrem
stark zugenommen von den neuen grenzen
die aus sicht der forscher für den
erhalt unserer natur wichtig sind
stechen zwei hervor klimawandel und
biodiversität die wissenschaftler halten
diese für besonders bedeutend und beide
haben wir bereits überschritten das
experten team möchte nun politiker und
konzerne von der dringlichkeit ihrer
studie überzeugen sie werden diese auf
dem wirtschaftsgipfel in davos kommende
woche vorstellen ob die experten ernst
genommen werden könnte von großer
bedeutung für die zukunft der menschheit
und der natur auf unserer erde seien
aber nicht nur auf der erde sondern auch
in unserer umlaufbahn sammelt sich
gefährlicher müll
mehr dazu findet ihr hier
weltraumschrott bedroht die erde zu rap
und zum blog geht es hier unten
allerdings und infos zu den themen wie
immer in der video beschreibe und was
meint ihr ist es schon zu spät unsere
erde noch zu retten wir verbrauchen er
unglaublich viel ressourcen diskutiert
es wie immer mit mir in den kommentaren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt